5 23 into Wednesday morning a viewer
question that you may have been
wondering about especially if you drive
the 95 515 between Eastern and
Charleston
Craig writes hey any information
regarding the 100 or so speed bumps in
the left lanes on both directions of the
freeway please tell us that indot's not
finished with this well Craig Nevada
Department of Transportation spokesman
Justin Hopkins says the problem is the
original rumble strips are raised above
the concrete grade
says it's temporary should be fixed with
a new configuration and repaving in
early fall
seriously if you've ever driven that it
is super bad Hopkins says endot
Engineers know the bumps are annoying
that they'll be checking to see if
there's anything they can do temporarily
until there's a permanent solution Craig
thanks for writing now for the online
version of this story and all of our
driving you crazy reports go to
8newsnow.com click traffic then driving
you crazy buckle up drive carefully and
please put on that phone you can join
the driving crazy conversation at
traffic 8 at 8newsnow.com